is it worth doing an MBA even though I
have a PhD and three years of Consulting
experience and here I want to generalize
this to the question is it worth to do
an NBA right especially if you already
have lots of academic experience and
here I'd say it very much depends on
your goals so usually just to advance in
your career I do not think that an NBA
is necessarily required however when an
NBA can help you is to make a transition
in your career so whenever you feel like
you are stuck in a specific area in your
career then the NBA is like the Joker
card that you can pull out once in your
life and that can really help you to
make that transition